you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another cold few Stern
video to go go here so a lot of us have
smartphones you see them absolutely
everywhere why is that though well if
he's de proprietary
smartphones really do tend to make our
lives easier making tasks that were once
impossible or very hard to do only just
a decade ago readily achievable keeping
this in mind
shouldn't we be seeing a whole lot of
Fringe innovative products using the
smartphone industry as a platform well
actually this does happen and a lot of
these products do exist but you may just
not have heard of them in this video
we'll take a look at five innovative
smartphone accessories that really are
new thinking number five okay so let's
start off with key tag two this is
basically an innovative Swiss Army knife
of technology you can charge it up using
a wall outlet or your car charger and
then power your phone in emergencies it
also doubles as a USB Drive so you can
chuck your data on there as well you can
also attach items that are prone to
getting lost and find them using the key
tag to app on your phone it also works
the other way around so if you lose your
phone you can press a button on the key
tag and make it ring so you can find it
easily enough that's not although the
buttons on the key tag too are actually
fully customizable via the key tag app
so you can do a whole lot of things like
remotely control your phone to trigger
fake calls or take photos or anything
else to your preference all in all I
like the thinking here and it's pretty
innovative ok so that was pretty
interesting but let's step things up a
notch with next pack number four so what
is it basically it's like phone blocks
for existing phones yes including
iPhones for those for you wondering
phone blocks is a modular phone idea
that lets you swap parts out instead of
buying an entirely new phone when a part
of your phone stops working or gets
outdated how does it work slide your
phone into the next pack case add some
modules access the app and enjoy the
unique feature
each module provides we've already
created twelve modules to get you going
and there's more to come next pack is
the first phone case that allows you to
switch Hardware between Android and
Apple devices this means you can trade
modules with friends and family and
experience the different features each
module provides if you do choose to
upgrade your phone all you'll need to do
is change your case and your modules
will always work with you the next back
team has been working on that idea for
two years and has just recently taken it
to Kickstarter it seems like a good
option until modular phones become more
established I wish them all the best
number three let's talk a little bit
about phones and their batteries right
now phone batteries kind of suck and
we're still waiting on some technologies
to improve that when you don't have
access to a charger one of the most
popular ways of making your phone lasts
a bit extra is by using a bulky external
battery pack but what if you could
charge your phone wirelessly inside a
sleeve instead so you can protect it
have easy access to it and also charge
at the same time enzyme novel cysts
ampere it's a really simple idea but it
goes a long way and here is the world's
first wireless charging policy
we've made it extremely easy to use for
people on the go ampere also comes the
USB output that allows you to charge
four times faster it is the only charger
that is paired with a mobile application
that allows you to control when charging
starts and monitor your battery life
precisely in minutes with amperes unique
tracking function never lose track of
your phone or ampere again number two
all right so let's move on and take a
look at all.i clip if you love your
photography and are up for trying
something new
ah a clip might just see you ala clip is
a range of three or four and one clip-on
lenses that revolutionize mobile
photography these lenses allow you to
take pictures in a whole different way
you can swap between fisheye wide-angle
ten times macro or 15 times macro lenses
the macro lens close-up shots that I've
seen that come out of the olloclip have
been especially incredible obviously
don't take my word for it just take a
look at some of these sample shots
I think technologies along this line
will see a big market if they do reduce
in price it's a great little piece of
technology that can really enhance that
quick smartphone snap unfortunately
though early clip isn't available for
every phone it's only available for all
the major iPhone and Samsung Galaxy
models cool so let's move on to the
final accessory of this video number one
this video will not be complete without
plug and play mobile VR it really is an
intriguing concept simply just slot your
phone into a box with two lenses on the
interior strap it to your head let the
gyroscopes accelerometers and software
do the rest and enter your own digital
world accessories such as Google
cardboard have made it cheap and easy
and other small companies are getting on
board with sturdier plastic versions and
then on the other end we have systems
such as the Samsung gear VR with a very
high degree of immersion comparable to
the oculus rift - the head tracking
movement of course if developers get on
board by making simple clever mobile
based VR apps
I think this category could easily take
off anyway that rounds out the 5
innovative smartphone add-ons for this
video if you can think of any others or
know any other innovative accessories
please let me know in the comments
section below
hopefully with time we start to see even
more refined mobile accessories that can
enhance the mobile experience anyway
this has been - gogo and you've been
watching cold fusion if you want to see
more stuff on technology interested in
alternative technology needs or want to
know some facts about some of the
world's biggest technology companies
please subscribe cheers guys have a good
one
cold fusion it's me thinking